こんにちはあ勢社長で生九段北の動画が結構ユーチューバーとかがよくいられるんです
けども
今回のゲストは
すごいですよどうぞ
ni
goo
ああああああ
糖代謝だから俺をあの弱
チェックケーキチャンネル紹介
興味ねぇまあ皆さんテレビではすごいもうてってなんというかなんですけど
ゆうちゅう会においてはを苦悩をダメなんですよ確かにそう
太刀掛そう
ブーブー今やてぃファーよ
坂しただけだろう
俺のことにの戻っ
入っています
あの女を俺関東っていうと文字です
フィリピンで描いたから
ブーブーて関東4 padi
ブーブー言っは
という意味で赤いもう系つはさての持ってるからお前もいやここ
なあこっちにやってもらうと思うわぐさん教皇ずにやってもらうのは可能に僕がやった
動画も不満排便して行ってもらうと思う
またそれやることになってるツールがどんなことだっていうのはまずと思うからそれが
ない工事だけだぞ
スマホをするにつけるバンカーニングってくるんしてるわーワンマンやってそう
指入れると落ちにくくなるから言うよ
うーん俺は昔それねーなー
あれ物色々固執しないカラー
あれ俺ったらがランカーニングってスマホどこにぺちゃね組んだらこんなんだに落ちる
わけがないと
いろんなものを連れてるって事はアンカーリングはたくさん天井にくっつけてそこで木
の板吊るせばプラントは作れると思う
をそれを恭子ずいってまぁわー
一回みましょうおい
[音楽]
これがうまくいくかどうかやって民度はああそうだねの時のバンカーリングしない
みたいとわけでしょ
旅立ちはこれよねこれ学教構図や類な事はあります
なんだよ
てなんで断るなら嘘や言えばさらに村を作ろう
ぴょん吉広ずゲージ入れ
year
どこよ cocco イメージですねこの1着選考の上だってチーズいちゃってし
なきゃいけもう来いやぁ
ミンドロいっしょ実はそうだねうん
tee
ブーブーしましたこれを全部ここにピュー do
co デー ne-yo
容姿と雪で洪水が付けてくれたぞ
ありがとうだ ok これでブラックができるぞ
だそうですで次はんすべて方が的に作っていくんですべて大変か
九段が成長してるのはブラブラグランプリでスプーン元を作っていくんでローンを通し
てこういう感性でなるほどロー
通すはいすいたかできる x マチがないコロトコフの
いただきますね
ブラパリに飽きられますよどうぞ
[音楽]
lost んだわーいや全部手作りだねほんとねそうですよでもそれないんだろうなぁ
どうぞ
打ったそう持っても結婚は2人ともてればいいなぁ
流通ばあさんのあるぞあっ追っかけジェサップ立つ
ステー長は今全部工事やってもらったら結局な
ツマー場合は才能がないテレビに朝刊でしましたーー
はいというえ完成したということではいっ
oj 乗ってみりあのっているよ俺がにしっかり乗ったら2人はゆっくり押してねっ回
じゃけど昨今はブランクを楽しみたいかな
あって流ん好きなお名前ご覧今オール好きなんだよから本当に
福よってわー
対数方までお渡し部屋
ちょっともってもってやることだよ
本当の良いけどねこれはれておりますだけどもう一回歌いいだけだったよ
ってこれらまた回し後になって今では怪獣かけるはネバー8 p 2
うわぁ
[音楽]
ええええええ
だこれ
[音楽]
me
うううう
ni
ええええええ
あっはぁ
まって今襲い来る前の炎上が
日目が合っ派